Hello, my name is Busty Okundaye. I'm with
UGC Technologies Shanghai, China. Yes I do
think the football is going to take place
here in 2010. It's actually very good for
the World Cup. It's very good for not only
South Africa, but the entire continent of
Africa. First of all there is going to be
precedent, meaning this is the first time
this has come into Africa. So hopefully it
will be coming again and won't be so much
of a headache coming a second, or third, or
fourth time to Africa. And in terms of other
areas beside football, does the infrastructure
that has been developed for this activity,
this football coming to South Africa, is a
lot of benefits for the masses in terms of
infrastructure or development. As another
benefit is creating jobs. Is skills also that
are very well needed not only in South Africa
but in other parts of Africa. But right now,
creating it here in South Africa. I think
this is a very, very good thing. And of course
when the football activities themself head
up here in South Africa there will be people
coming from all over the world not just from
Africa or from South Africa alone. And these
people will be bringing in a whole lot of,
what will I say, financial stuff that they
will come here and spend in South Africa.
So that's also beneficially for South Africa.
And besides that, there are other things like
follow up effects that will actually happen
in South Africa. So a lot of not just football
relationship will be happening among those
peoples of the world, but also there are business
issues and friendship issues. Also cultural
issues that will follow as a result of this.
So I think it's very beneficial not only to
South Africa, but to the entire continent.
Thank you.